Larry David has spent more than a decade
railing against social slights both real
and imagined on Curb Your Enthusiasm the
sort of biographical character proved
that misanthropy can be very funny I'll
be it pretty annoying at some points and
while audiences were entertained by all
those awkward encounters a lot of kerbs
characters got pretty disrespected by
his bonehead behavior on the show here
are the worst things Larry David ever
did on Curb Your Enthusiasm yes
stepfathers count empathy doesn't come
easily to the curved version of Larry
David that's one of the reasons why we
love him and Larry's complete inability
to give a crap can even push him a
little too far as in the first season
finale the group in the episode larry
runs into an old flame who asked larry
to accompany her to an incest survivors
group and of course he makes it weird
when larry learns that lisa was molested
by her stepfather his reaction is less
than supportive are you sure that you
qualify his stepfather is that
considered incest and while sitting in
on the therapy session he invents a
story about an uncle who molested him as
a child my name is Todd and I'm an
incest survivor by the end of the
episode the group's leader comes face to
face with Larry's actual uncle and
promptly rips him apart in front of
everyone yikes
the TiVo tipping point even Larry's
long-suffering wife Cheryl had to call
it quits eventually in season seven
after finding herself in a wildly
turbulent flight Cheryl calls Larry to
say goodbye for what she thinks might be
forever but Larry's too distracted by
his TV repairman to listen to her call
me back in ten minutes okay for Cheryl
that's it it's not just the phone call
of course you can't do anything like a
normal person but the TiVo incident is
the straw that breaks the camel's back
and leaves her to file for divorce after
that most of the couples mutual friends
side with Cheryl throwing Larry's social
life into disarray and his favorite
restaurant refuses to seat him but the
biggest tragedy to Larry the TiVo still
doesn't work on really Vibol Seinfeld
George Costanza is partially based on
Larry David so it could be a little hard
to tell them apart sometimes just like
when George faked a handicap to get a
job Larry starts dating a woman in a
wheelchair and
is it to his advantage he starts out by
saying well this by the way what's the
proper term I said you got what is it
what are you disabled and again what for
yeah well those are challenged so you
challenged then in true Larry David
fashion he starts using others sympathy
for her as a social shield for himself
he then hits on another woman in a
wheelchair but runs into Denis at a
party so instead of owning up to his own
terrible decisions he sticks Wendy in a
closet before Denis discovers his dirty
secret oh the hell is she one day
wheelchair
needless to say neither of those women
ever came back into the picture
grave-robber you don't have to be among
the living to suffer Larry David
shenanigans Marty funkhauser one of
Larry's friends knows this all too well
Larry attends his father's open casket
funeral and discovers that Marty's dad
will be buried with his prized golf club
which Larry also loves instead of
respecting the dead guy's wishes though
he switches the club out for a
replacement and everyone finds out about
it in the middle of the service then
when funkhouser's mother passes away
Larry does it again not only does he
literally laugh at Marty's face when he
expresses his grief you can okay Little
Orphan Funkhouser
but he also proceeds to steal flowers
from the roadside memorial that's built
near the site of her car accident
Larry stakes the bouquets to offer
flowers to people for free then he
steals the dead lady's perfume to give
to Cheryl and of course Larry has no
remorse because Funkhouser owed him $50
anyway for Christ's sake Larry Larry
David incented a lot of religious ire
after peeing on Jesus after he's
prescribed a medication that makes him
urinate out of control the accidentally
gets a drop of his pee on Jesus and
decides not to wipe it away that's when
the paintings owners think the image is
producing real tears and chaos ensues
why yes yes he did
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
you
[Music]